there's a battle right now going on in
our culture about self-definition I am
whatever I say I am oh I say you're
gripped so firmly by your sexuality that
your sexuality now proclaims that it's
you and you believe that now everyone
with an ounce of sense and iota of sense
and this is actually what defines sense
knows perfectly well if they only do
exactly what they want to do in
accordance with the whim of the moment
which then becomes their God right
because if you're motivated by the whim
of the moment and you place that above
all else that is now your god well if
sexual motivation is your god you will
end up in something indistinguishable
from hell because you will you will
misuse other people you will make them
objects of your own narrow and immediate
desire and you'll have no relationships
you'll exploit everyone including
yourself and there's that's no way to
live